laughter you guys smile that Kenny said
it'd be runny yeah what a [ __ ] my stuff
is like not working
noobs I can see the ground that's nice
sure whatever how's it going Ken hey you
know I'm just gonna win we'll see about
that
Oh watch it no was even an arrow come on
no it's not Ken will suck at [ __ ] [ __ ]
that is so unfair
this game is hax oh [ __ ] I got speed and
blow it up Oh back sis boxes so many
banks eat the boxes what you gonna do oh
[ __ ] oh it's on its own Donkey Kong No
gusting I hit like everything you could
possibly hit I'm looking at you guys
instead of me I keep just forgetting I
have to press buttons and [ __ ] you pink
and red people look the same
that's racist that's so racist I always
have to edit your racist remarks minks
everytime everybody everybody jeez
thanks is being racist again I remember
one time I had to edit out Petey paws
racist comment yeah I never say anything
racist don't you dare use that ground
you die so fast right here every time
whoa sweet bit don't you dare use that
grapple don't you dare close me out back
what is this
okay guys that's been a pleasure just
[ __ ] kidding go suck it dalek Donkey
Kong that's slide dad oh thanks for
taking my gun Ken don't worry about it
I don't need to win I hate I hate
winning it's not fun oh oh what's up
what's up you [ __ ] you didn't give me
the boost you serious you don't even
know what whoa why am i why am i winning
why am i winning we don't gotta go anyw
whoa bro [ __ ]
don't you dare backs me crap I miss the
boost uh-oh don't you do you think
you're gonna close man huh rocket not on
me Josh what the fabulous power fiber
less power
I got the boost oh look at this [ __ ] my
HS Oh the bumps is gonna come the bombs
are gonna come the bombs are gonna come
the beams are gonna came the babes oh
what a pity pop ow whoa yep I just I
just want some footage of me winning
that's just trying Oh what's up why why
do you do that god I hate you all no
good oh thank god I mean it I don't know
I don't know and I just want to be a ho
okay I do more twerking then in that
case it's tight no go for 10 don't you
dare grapple but it might grapple miss
when it's me guys it's been a pleasure I
just [ __ ] kill it kill everyone why
don't you die whoa you guys are fast yes
Go Go Power Rangers
come on baby never gonna give you up
never gonna let you down never gonna be
fabulous and twerk beards
oh yeah going on boxes go on the box
[ __ ] [ __ ]
boxes don't you really screw you boxes
everywhere boxes rock no no no no no
starting [ __ ] tennis two points wins
Kenny's cheating pH is neat uninstall I
mean Kenny's not following that don't
worry I have a grapple
don't make me grapple you minx I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna make you okay you're
yet makes you lost your power you lost
your Zen what's up
it's okay it's okay to cry but here it
comes here it comes
that's what I do for living
[ __ ] I believed your bombs up I have
had like my mojo and I tell them the
pensive joke and I can't don't worry I
laid it out as always they will come
back we have to beat can suck a dick you
[ __ ] what
this is my turn yeah socket sure you a
waste of that yeah I waste like I waste
my space with it oh nice nice light bro
you call that a slide I call it a [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't you call it I run faster than
you
did you realize I think it's because I'm
prettier probably it's free cuz they
unit going on I'll probably do that yeah
it penetrates the air it's true
aerodynamics jeez it's true don't
grapple me grapple now minx grapple now
thanks
later noob oh [ __ ]
part of the plan you wanna present oh
[ __ ] hey you want to present BAM what's
up
gonna get ya gonna get ya oh yeah do
that know what you like for me Oh
cheats cheats Oh check homie it's
terrible what you gonna do with the
boxes now huh boxes boxes what oh how do
you grapple without a grappling I don't
even know [ __ ]
I'm awful at this game yeah I can hear
you oh man this is so intense guys give
me pause just wait for a second okay
don't run I promise
idiot we did this BAM this dead
the minks bomb is terrible I named the
bomb after you aren't you happy
whatever you shouldn't it's a [ __ ]
game gave it over I'm sorry now I feel
bad I shared a single tanner you know
what you know what what's up no no damn
seriously stop tryharding it's
embarrassing
everyone knows you're tryharding cuz
you're not saying a word no wait let's
wait up for Ken and then I got to great
that what races yes not racing well he
was like oh wait no I'm confused
edit that out oh wait what is going on
with the skype you guys sound really
weird
he's so really weird gotta you everyone
sounds fine to me
okay well you guys were son it rings I
sorry I have to I have to catch up I had
to catch up what do you want
ken is charting what am I supposed to do
hey come on come on I did what I had to
do mmm yeah oh man oh I'm so sorry
angry now so upset no it's gonna win
come on we keep going forever Lilly